[Musique]
les touristes s'activent dans le
socoactif de Doha à la veille du coup
d'envoi
contreversée mais qui ne doit pas porter
ombrage au sport espère cet américain
le président de la FIFA s'est livré à
une attaque en règle contre ces
détracteurs occidentaux dans un
monologue de plus de 50 minutes
faire la morale relève de l'hypocrisiele
quand votre situation n'est peut-être
pas aussi reluisante le bilan katari en
matière de droits humains n'a pourtant
rien d'enviable la construction des
infrastructures sportives s'est fait au
prix d'innombrables vie de travailleurs
étrangers le statut des travailleurs au
Qatar qui est absolument horrible qui a
été documenté c'est proche de
l'esclavage today I feel
my grand walk mais son salaire annuel de
plus de 2 millions d'euros très hygiani
Infantino qui deviendra plus tôt le seul
et unique candidat à sa succession à la
tête de la FIFA son prédécesseur cette
Blatter poursuivi puis blanchi pour
allégation de crimes financier avait
fait du Qatar le pays haute de cette
Coupe du Monde c'est vraiment une
gouvernance qui est celle d'un seul
homme qui a un pouvoir quasi absolu et
la gouvernance de la FIFA s'améliore pas
malgré les promesses au fil des
différents scandales qui a eu
mais comment accepter une grande messe
du SOCAR dans un pays où la diversité
est punie malgré les protections
promises pendant le tournoi
pour ces Allemands l'expérience est
gâchée
dit-il et traverser au Qatar seulement
pour les matchs de l'Allemagne la goutte
de trop c'est l'interdiction des
boissons alcoolisées près des stades
annoncées pas plus tard qu'hier beaucoup
de gens se disent mais à ce moment-là
les autres engagements de Qatar que
va-t-il se passer est-ce qu'il va
revenir également sur l'autorisation de
ne pas poursuivre les gens qui
s'afficheraient homosexuels alors que
c'est illégal au Qatar
les festivités sont lancées pour 28
jours pendant lesquels le Qatar et la
FIFA tenteront de redorer leur image ici
Jean-Philippe news Radio-Canada Montréal